[Music]
china has a lot at stake in afghanistan
china shares a border with afghanistan
and it has some economic investments
there like copper mine and some oil
blocks but what's really really
important for china in afghanistan is
making sure that political instability
and violence doesn't spill over the
border into neighboring pakistan where
it has more than 50 billion dollars
worth of investments in the
china-pakistan economic corridor that's
stuff like infrastructure like roads and
power plants things like that
afghanistan is also in a central
location for china's broader belt and
road initiative which stretches across
central asia so beijing does not want
anything from afghanistan to interfere
with those broader plans
the other thing that china doesn't want
to happen in afghanistan is for kuiger
separatists or militants from its
western xinjiang region
to get any support
or aid from the taliban in afghanistan
because those groups have actually
cooperated in the past and china has
blamed
those huiger separatists
for the crackdown that we've seen in
xinjiang which western countries say
amounts to genocide
the last time the taliban took power in
afghanistan in the mid 90s china was a
small player in global affairs its
economy wasn't that big
and it just generally didn't have
that big of a presence in international
affairs fast forward more than 20 years
and and the picture has completely
changed china has
regional interests that stretch from its
border with afghanistan all the way
through central asia
it has a tense relationship with the
united states which has had a military
presence in a country on its on china's
border
for more than two decades so when the
taliban even before the taliban took
power uh this time and took control of
kabul
beijing
had actually hosted taliban negotiators
senior officials to china
and and talked about what was going to
happen they called china's foreign
minister wang yi called the the taliban
an important political force in
afghanistan even before they had
captured the capital so
china came out above and in front of all
the other different countries in the
world
and and kind of voiced support boosting
the legitimacy of the taliban so um
china's approach now
compared to before is is just worlds
apart
[Music]
china's been pretty circumspect with the
chaos that's unfolded uh amid the us's
uh hasty withdrawal
they've tried to talk about
you know a sort of moderate maybe
inclusive taliban government coming into
power
but at the moment i think it's clear
that china like a bunch of other
countries is quite nervous about what's
unfolding in afghanistan right now the
last time the taliban took power
there were all sorts of regressive
policies towards women and girls and
other people in afghanistan so i think
at the moment china hopes that the
taliban will not do anything to alienate
its support but i think at the moment
china's being pretty cautious and just
hoping that what happens in afghanistan
is not what happened last time
[Music]
you